[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrter herr präsident meine
damen und herren
was sind das für zeiten wo ein gespräch
über bäume fast ein verbrechen ist weil
es ein schweigen über so viele untaten
einschließt der toll brecht ja ja hier
wird viel geredet aber über wirkliche
untaten den terror der antifa wird hier
im bundestag und in der gesellschaft
noch mehr gestiegen
und wenn ich geschwiegen werden kann
wenn geredet werden muss weil es nicht
anders geht weil wieder was passiert
dieses gebäudes wird zurzeit zb von der
antifa angegriffen
dann wird bagatellisiert verharmlost
abgestritten oder umgedeutet alles mit
der zielsetzung eines zu tun nämlich
nichts zu tun und bei ihnen wundert
nicht dass nicht mal frau renate sind ja
auch da sie gehören ja eigentlich zur
antifa aber bei ihnen hier von der union
da wundert mich doch sehr das ist
freiheit feigheit vor dem feind
man kann dankbar sein dass präsident
trump in den usa die initiative
ergriffen hat mit gutem beispiel
vorangeht er hat der antifa den krieg
erklärt er ist entschlossen
durchzugreifen und die ordnung die
beispielsweise in seattle in gefahr
geraten ist wieder herzustellen so eine
entschlossenheit würde ich mir auch von
einer deutschen regierung wünschen
[Musik]
antifa was ist das es ergibt sich ein
diffuses bild verschiedener er locker
verbundgruppen mit unterschiedlicher
intensität an gewaltbereitschaft dem
ungefährlich operierenden ideologisch
verstrahlten spinnern oder vom welt
schmerzgeplagte jugendlicher
existierende mantey familie straff
organisierte schlägerbanden die minutiös
geplante anschläge ausführen und es
häufig schaffen mittelbar über
öffentliche gelder finanziert zu werden
das ist besonders skandalös
sie tun das nicht um gehalten sondern
ganz offen
ein blick ins internet reicht der aus
und verweise hier beispielhaft auf die
seite antifa berlin info hier werden die
begangenen einzeltaten
gewaltverherrlichender weise
zusammengestellt wer meldet sowas wer
kümmert sich da groben der vol/a sie
lachen sich hat tod nach wo ist da die
polizei warum passiert da nichts
die antwort ist ganz einfach weil in
dieser gesellschaft linke gewalt mehr
und mehr hoffähig gemacht wurde weil die
politisch mediale klasse ein klima der
akzeptanz gegenüber linker gewalt
geschaffen hat und weil linke gewalt
nicht in das medial geschaffene bild
passt wonach nur der rechtsextremismus
gefährlich sei ich will jetzt gar nicht
über die ganzen attacken auf unsere
büros oder fdp hin oder den angriff auf
frank buckles diesen hinterhältigen
angriff am montag dieser woche ist die
antifa in leipzig unterwegs gewesen hat
das lokal der schwester der schwester
die hier gar nichts zu tun hat mit
irgendwelchen politischen dingen dass
die schwester von
werth größe angegriffen das ist
sippenhaft sowas und das ist nicht in
ordnung hinzuweisen es aber darauf dass
die geister die man rief auch die
eigenen leute treffen können ja so wurde
kurioserweise helge lind spd sie hier
im april dieses jahres zum ziel und sein
büro in wuppertal beschädigt neben der
selbstermächtigung zu gewalttaten im
kleinen oder wie beim g20-gipfel in
hamburg im großen ist die antifa stets
bemüht rechtsfreie räume für sich zu
schaffen räume wie connewitz in leipzig
rote flora in hamburg rigaer straße in
berlin räume in denen sie die kontrolle
haben und in denen der rechtsstaat
praktisch ausgestellt wird da macht das
was man will insbesondere entzieht man
sich in solchen no go areas allen
verpflichtungen und stellt sich wie
reichs bürger außerhalb der gemeinschaft
es geht diesen leuten nicht um
politische ziele es geht diese leute und
krawall spaß am zerstören und eintauchen
den rechtsfreie räume
gerechtfertigt wird sowas damit wird im
linksextremistischen geschwafel
das muss aufhören und vor allen dingen
muss die rechtsstaatliche ordnung in
diesem land gegen diese typen endlich
durchgesetzt werden die antifa muss
verboten werden
vielen dank
hier ins meyer für die fdp fraktion hat
die beiden anträge seiner fraktion zum
verbot der antifa oder zur ächtung der
antifa hier vorgestellt und ich muss
eine kleine informationen nachschieben
hat am anfang seiner rede gesagt das
gebäude werde wohl angegriffen
von der antifa es ist tatsächlich so
dass ein offenbar verwirrter einzelner
mensch hier an der fassade lang
geklettert ist wahrscheinlich sogar
schon hier am reichstagsgebäude mit der
antifa scheint das alles nichts zu tun
zu haben marion wendt für die
unionsfraktion ist mitglied im
innenausschuss und am pult dieser ist
wie von dieser fraktion nicht anders zu
erwarten widersprüchlich und erfasst die
breite des problems überhaupt gar nicht
woher soll die inhaltliche breite
überhaupt kommen wenn ein antrag nicht
mal 24 stunden vor dieser debatte
vorliegt zum text bereits im ersten
absatz ihres pamphlets möchte darf
lediglich größten gefahren für unsere
gesellschaft benennen den
linksextremismus den islamistischen
terrorismus
und genau das war es sie vergisst aber
interessanterweise den rechtsextremismus
zu erwähnen wie praktisch aber auch
nicht verwunderlich wenn man selber eine
rechtsextremistische partei ist
extremisten als extremisten zu erkennen
und zu benennen ist kernaufgabe des
verfassungsschutzes sagte vor einigen
tagen jörg müller leiter der abteilung
verfassungsschutz in brandenburg neben
seinen kollegen in thüringen hat er nun
als zweiter die afg zum
beobachtungsobjekt eingestuft und die
alternative für deutschland damit klar
als eine extremistische partei in
deutschland benannt
ich zitiere weiter dem landesverband
brandenburg sind extremistische
positionierungen von fdp-mitgliedern
zuzurechnen
und jetzt hören sie gut zu dir
insbesondere die menschenwürde und das
demokratie und rechtsstaat prinzip
verletzten
und es geht noch weiter die
brandenburger fdp hat sich seit ihrer
gründung stetig radikalisiert und wird
mittlerweile von bestrebungen dominiert
die ganz eindeutig gegen unsere
freiheitliche demokratische grundordnung
gerichtet sind eher wenn ein comeback
als einen überzeugten rechtsextremisten
meine damen und herren auch mir scheint
es dass nazis de kall witt und co nicht
nur ein flügel der fdp sondern der ganze
vogel sind
soll ich ihnen nun liebe kolleginnen von
der ard die definition von
glaubwürdigkeit einmal anhand ihres
vorgelegten antrages erläutern
gerne doch sie wollen einen zitat
glaubwürdige kampf der politik gegen
gewalttätigen politischen extremismus
führen sind aber selbst ein
beobachtungsobjekt des verfassungsschutz
sie können aus meiner sicht gar keinen
kampf gegen extremisten führen wenn sie
selber reiche sind und vom rechtsstaat
bekämpft werden müssen und das werden
wir mit aller konsequenz tun
ich glaube ja dass ihn dieser konflikt
und dieser umstand bewusst ist sie
versuchen nun mit hinweis auf andere
extremisten von sich abzulenken
vergessen dabei aber mit einem finger
auf andere zeigt zeigt mit drei fingern
auf sich wie schändlich
wieso der daumen zeigt er nicht
[Applaus]
wie schändlich anstatt sich aber
kritisch mit dieser tatsache auseinander
zu setzen wollen sie die öffentliche
debatte lieber auf das problem des
linksextremismus schieben das lassen wir
ihnen nicht durchgehen weiter zum text
sie rufen dazu auf den rechtsstaat und
die demokratie schützen zu wollen
aus meiner sicht gehört es sich da auf
alle arten von extremismus einzugehen um
die gesamte problematik darzustellen
oder für die ard ist das nicht nötig
rechtsextremismus scheint wird diese
partei ein nachrangiges problem zu sein
es wird einseitig auf die ganz gewiss
bestehende problematik des
linksextremismus und des islamismus
abgestellt in ihrem text zum anti
extremistischen grundkonsens wird halten
sie sich fest genau zweimal von
rechtsextremismus gesprochen
nur zweimal in einem antrag der
vermeintlich alle extremistischen
strömungen verurteilen den wahnsinn
auch werden politisch motiviert auch
werden politisch motivierte angriffe auf
politiker genannt
allerdings zeigen sie nur diejenigen
taten auf die ausschließlich einen
linksextremistischen bezug haben
peinlich die fdp war und ist bis heute
nicht mutig genug um beispielsweise den
mord an walter lübke in irgendeiner
weise zu erwähnen und zu vorteilen
schämen sie sich
wie soll ich sie eine partei die unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
offensichtlich unterminiert ernst nehmen
sie wollen in extremistische strömung
bekämpfen tolerieren und unterstützen
aber innerhalb ihrer eigenen reihen
rechtsextremisten wie geht das zusammen
ich musste sogar laut lachen als ich in
ihrem antrag gelesen habe dass sie sich
als partei zitat in der mitte der
gesellschaft sehen was für eine
heuchelei werte kollegen der auf dem ich
lasse ich ihn nicht zu sich als die
wahren verfechter der demokratie
auszugeben
denn das sind sie auf gar keinen fall
ich lasse ihr spielchen einfachen euch
zu damit extremismus spielt man nicht
ich akzeptiere nicht dass sie mit ihrer
gefährlichen rhetorik hier im herzen
unserer demokratie in diesem hause in
diesem deutschen bundestag unseren
rechtsstaat bedroht und ihn zum narren
machen wollen seien sie lieber still und
machen sie sich nicht noch lächerlicher
wir als große koalition bekämpfen die
antifa genauso hart wie islamistische
terroristen und natürlich auch die
gefahren von rechts
nachdem das zeigt sich heute wieder
einmal ist selber das problem in unserem
land und kann ich der problemlöser sein
ihre anträge lege meine fraktion nicht
es hat konsequenterweise ab vielen dank
maria werden für die unionsfraktion es
mit mit dem innenausschuss und obfrau im
innenausschuss linda teuteberg aus der
fdp-fraktion die ja bekanntermaßen auch
generalsekretärin ihrer partei ist und
sie ist die nächste rednerin in dieser
debatte in der es um zwei anträge der
afg fraktion geht
der präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der schutz von rechtsstaat und
demokratie der ist uns freien demokraten
wahrlich wichtig dafür brauchen wir
allerdings keinen einzigen antrag wie
den heute vorliegenden welches und
demokratie werden von verschiedenen
seiten gefährdet von extremisten seien
sie rechts links oder religiös motiviert
und auf keinem auge darf der
demokratische rechtsstaat lehnt sein wie
wir haben ja über diesen antrag auch im
september letzten jahres schon neu
debattiert und was ich allerdings nicht
geahnt hätte oder nicht gewünscht habe
ich habe damals darauf hingewiesen dass
auch redefreiheit gegen blockaden gegen
widerrechtliche verhinderung von
veranstaltungen verteidigt werden muss
und wir haben im herbst ein paar
beispiele dafür gesehen
auch das ist weiterhin wichtig die
redefreiheit für alle auf dem boden der
verfassung stehen meinungen zu
verteidigen und zugleich sein und
übrigens warum wir auch gegen diesen
antrag sind weil wir tatsächlich die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
so ernst nehmen dass auch die
gewaltenteilung dazu gehört und die
behörden in unserem land keine konkreten
aufträge brauchen aus dem parlament wen
sie wie zu beobachten und zu beurteilen
haben wir vertrauen darauf dass das nach
den kriterien von recht und gesetz
geschieht
[Applaus]
zugleich ist allerdings dieser antrag
ein guter anlass auf ein paar dinge
einzugehen die tatsächlich klar gestellt
werden müssen und die wichtig sind zb
auch das staatliche gewaltmonopol
wirklich zu verteidigen
wir reden ja heute mit blick auf das
mittelalter vom feder unwesen weil wir
besseres kennen nämlich den rechtsstaat
mit vollziehende gewalt ohne
selbstjustiz sondern mit dem staatlichen
gewaltmonopol und das gilt es zu
verteidigen und das geht manchmal unter
in manchen debatten so wie zb nach dem
silvester zusammenstößen zwischen
demonstranten und polizei in leipzig
connewitz
da gab es auch diskussionen darüber ob
es jetzt hier polizeigewalt gegeben
hätte oft geht das aber am thema vorbei
denn das setzt ja voraus dass die
polizei generell
nicht gewalt anwenden dürfe die frage
ist ob sie verhältnismäßig und
rechtmäßig gar nicht hat denn nicht wie
infor staatlichen zeiten begegnen sich
da zwei clans die wir im buddelkasten
dann streiten wer hat zu zanken
angefangen der staat ist nicht zur
gewaltlosigkeit verpflichtet ist dazu
verpflichtet das recht einzuhalten
und deshalb muss das verhältnis auch
asymmetrisch seien zum beispiel zwischen
den demonstranten und der polizei
denn allein der staat darf zwingen das
ist inhalt des staatlichen
gewaltmonopols und des rechtsstaates
wir tragen in der familie keine waffe
weil wir uns weil wir uns schätzen und
aufeinander verlassen und wir tragen
auch sonst keine weil wir darauf
vertrauen dass die polizei uns im
zweifelsfall in unserem rechtsstaat
schützt und dieses vertrauen ist wichtig
und deshalb gewalt verstanden als
legitimierter durch das gesetz
legitimierter zwang der ist auch aufgabe
der polizei gegen den willen der
betroffenen die stärke unseres
freiheitlichen rechtsstaates ist dass
jeder bürger die möglichkeit hat die
rechtmäßigkeit überprüfen zu lassen vor
unabhängigen verwaltungsgerichten das
unterscheidet ihn von anderen früheren
staaten auf deutschen boden und
rechtskräftige verfügungen der behörden
und gerichte die müssen auch weiterhin
durchgesetzt werden zuverlässig denn sie
sind mehr als bitten oder empfehlungen
die debatten über polizeigewalt sind in
diesem sinne regelmäßig verzerrt und ob
ein bestimmter einsatz legitimiert war
oder nicht das ist zu prüfen ja genau
und deshalb müssen die bürgerrechte auch
gegen gewalttätige geschützt werden das
ist genau inhalt dessen was ich gerade
beschreibe die polizei ist rechtlich
gebunden und sie muss aber auch andere
bürger schützen wenn andere bürger nicht
bereit sind sich selbst an die
rechtsordnung zu halten denn
der inhalt unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung und um deren
schutz geht es ja in dieser debatte
der ist eben auch dass jeder daran
gebunden ist seine politischen ziele nur
friedlich rechtmäßig zu verfolgen mit
solchen mitteln und insofern führen
diese diskussion in die irre
auch die die übrigens mein polizei als
strukturelle gewalt bezeichnen zu können
unser rechtsstaat er bietet die
möglichkeit durch wahlen die politischen
verhältnisse zu beeinflussen über
gerichte rechtmäßiges handeln zu
überprüfen zu lassen und rechtswidriges
feststellen zu lassen und das müssen wir
verteidigen und diejenigen die die
knochen dafür hinhalten auch
grundsätzlich mit wertschätzung begegnen
und schließlich ist auch sehr wichtig
was dazu zu sagen ob denn der begriff
antifaschismus antifas der eigentlich
bedeutet für unsere für unseren kampf um
die freiheitliche demokratie
es ist ein sehr ambivalentes begriff und
ich finde man muss unterscheiden
zwischen nach seinen ursprüngen wenn ich
etwa an den schwur von buchenwald 1945
denke so war das ein anti faschismus der
aus der konkreten erinnerungen ja aus
der erschütterung des erlebten erwuchs
und der zunächst als eine
überparteiliche und auch internationale
sammelbewegung gegen den
nationalsozialismus sein erbe und für
eine friedliche und freiheitliche welt
anfing
das ist zum einen zu sehen aber es ist
auch zu sehen wie der begriff zunehmend
missbraucht wurde
und so wie der begriff faschismus
vielschichtig ist und wissenschaftlich
und politisch unterschiedlich gebraucht
wird gilt das auch für antifaschismus
es gibt eine vielzahl von verwendungen
im linksextremistischen sinne auch gerne
als diffamierung aller abweichenden
ansichten wir haben gerade vor zwei
tagen in diesem haus ein ereignis des 17
juni gedacht wo das auch angewendet
wurde
andersdenkende als faschistische
provokateure zu diffamieren
es war eine legitimation ideologie auch
für die ddr diktatur
es ist agitation linksextremistischer
vorfeldorganisationen und eine
bündnisstrategie linksextreme
tischer vorfeldorganisationen und ein
argumentationsmuster agitation feld von
autonomen und deshalb stellt sich doch
die frage welchen wert hat dieser
begriff überhaupt für unseren einsatz
für freiheit und demokratie kaum
er hat kein analytischen wert er hat
keinen praktischen wert denn überzeugte
demokraten die sind selbstverständlich
immer in opposition zur faschistischen
bewegungen aber längst nicht alle
antifaschisten sind überzeugte
demokraten
denn deshalb ist die frage worauf kommt
es denn jetzt eigentlich an und an kommt
es auf den positiven einsatz für unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
in dem wir dazu stehen und zwar
entschieden nicht schamhaft und nicht
irgendwie nach politischen präferenzen
opportunistisch eingeschränkt dass jeder
seine politischen ziele nur gewaltfrei
rechtmäßig demokratisch verfolgt dass
wir jeder art von menschenverachtung
entgegentreten und nicht durch eine
andere menschenverachtung ersetzen oder
legitimieren und dass wir für den anti
totalitären konsens einstehen gegen
andere antidemokraten zu sein macht
einen selbst noch nicht zum demokraten
dazu gehört mehr dass man nämlich diese
friedliche freiheitliche ordnung selber
aktiv verteidigt gegen ihre feinde und
dafür werden wir eintreten auch ohne
diesen antrag hier grundsätzliche
anmerkungen zu den grundlagen des
rechtsstaats von der generalsekretärin
der fdp von linda teuteberg
generalsekretärs auch uli goltsch und
zwar der spd in bayern
aber er ist auch mitglied im
innenausschuss und der nächste redner
hier im parlament
vielen dank herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich kann
eigentlich gleich an meiner vorrednerin
anknüpfen und möchte eine software ganz
am anfang gestellt
doch guttenberg alle antifaschisten sind
selbstredend und atomar ganz automatisch
demokraten weil sie sich gegen
es muss wenden und weil sie für
demokratie und freiheit kämpfen
ich möchte aber auch dem zur debatte
stehenden antrag zu sprechen kommen und
ihnen sagen
in der überschrift ihres antrags heißes
jahr an tv verbot prüfen und ich hab das
mal für sie gemacht und kommen zu dem
schluss dass sie sich bei ihren antrag
um eine themaverfehlung handel und ich
möchte ihnen ab märz erklären wie ich zu
diesem schluss komme es steht am kiefer
in der überschrift aber darin enthalten
ist die debatte um linksextremismus sie
hätten in der schule in geschichte
besser aufpassen sollen den
antifaschismus hat nichts mit
linksextremismus zu tun und im übrigen
auch nicht seine symbole der kollege
deutschland keine zwischenfragen der
kollegin teuteberg
gerade gesagt dass auch jeder
antifaschist demokrat sein würden sie
das zum einen und ich finde das eine
sehr ernste frage wenn es uns mit diesem
kampf für die demokratie ernst nehmen
sie das zum einen auch für stalin zum
beispiel sagen der mindestens bis 39 und
ab 100 1941 wieder erklärte antifaschist
war aber bestimmt nicht demokrat und
haben sie haben sie die nein ich sage
dass man dich bitte ausreden
ich frage das sehr bewusst auch in hohen
respekt vor der geschichte auch der
sozialdemokraten die selber von
kommunisten auch diffamiert wurden in
der weimarer republik und da sollte
davon abgelenkt werden das von rechts
und links die republik in die zange
genommen wurde und deshalb kann ich nur
sehr davor warnen diesen umkehrschluss
zu ziehen dass jeder antifaschist auch
demokrat sei und jeder der die
geschichte insbesondere übrigens auch im
osten unseres landes kennt weiß dass das
nicht der fall ist ihre eigene partei
wurde mit einer zwangsvereinigung zur
sed ebenfalls unter dem rubrum
antifaschismus unterdrückt und deshalb
sollten wir da sehr differenziert
wenn wir erstmal ganz direkt auf ihre
frage zur antwort nein heute berg josef
stalin war kein hand die faschisten aber
kein demokrat um das mal zu sagen aber
so geht s demokraten und so geht das
antifaschisten und vielen anderen dass
ihre symbole und ihre botschaft auch oft
missbraucht wurde
bei uns eine spd wir reden uns zb mit
genossinnen und genossen an
und das seit 157 jahren
und da wird uns das auch nicht davon
abhalten das in der ddr
diese anrede auch mal missbraucht wurde
und ad absurdum geführt wurde wenn sie
mich fragen das hat uns davon nicht ab
und zu geht es vielen symbolen und
vielen ausdrücken und so natürlich auch
dem antifaschismus auch dieser begriff
wurde in der geschichte viel viel viel
zu oft missbraucht um von eigenen
defiziten und so womöglich sogar wenn
sie stalin ansprechen von der eigenen
menschenfeindlichkeit und vom eigenen
extremismus oder ganz persönlichen
faschismus abzulenken
aber wir waren beim thema antifaschismus
im jahr 2020 und darüber hinaus und bei
seinen symbolen und der frage was
darunter zu verstehen ist und wer
womöglich dahinter steckt und ich möchte
ihnen das bei dieser gelegenheit noch
mal erklären was es damit auf sich hat
das zum beispiel ist die
antifaschistische aktion steinau die
kennen sie gegen die haben sie diese
woche erst wieder vor gericht verloren
das ist die antifaschistische aktion
eiserne front seit 1931
das ist unsere jugend organisation die
nicht vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet
wird aber antifaschistische aktion wird
und es wird sie wahrscheinlich nicht
überraschen was zum abschluss kommt das
antifaschistische aktion seit 157 jahren
sehr geehrte damen und
ich finde es alles in allem mehr als
schwierig wenn man selbst im fokus des
verfassungsschutzes wegen politischen
extremismus es steht dass man verkrampft
versucht den scheinwerfer in die andere
richtung zu drehen was schon im
kindergarten nicht funktioniert sehr
geehrte damen und herren und das
funktioniert auch hier im deutschen
bundestag nicht ihr flügel ist
nachweislich rechtsextrem landesverbände
der afg sind unter beobachtung des
verfassungsschutzes ihre
jugendorganisation wird beobachtet die
ganze afd wird überprüft vom
verfassungsschutz
wir haben es immer gesagt und sorgen es
auch heute die rechtsstaatliche fassade
kann auch der bundesverband nicht lange
aufrechterhalten seien sie sich dessen
ganz sicher von dem amt die
extremistischen grundkonsens den cia
immer fordern und so heute wieder wenden
sie sich doch tag für tag aufs neue ab
und wer bei ihnen ein linksextremist ist
zeigt zb ein tweet eines
fdp-landtagsabgeordneten ard und zdf
seien linksextreme medien
und was fällt ihnen was fällt ihnen zu
der gesellschaftlichen debatte im
zusammenhang mit black line natürlich
rassismus gegen weiße das also auch für
antifaschismus nach ihrer leser und
linksextremist und deshalb
wahrscheinlich niemanden mehr
sie gehen mit diesem begriff ohnehin
inflationär und es ist unrecht
es ist unrecht gegenüber allen
antifaschisten auch in den reihen der
spd und im ganzen deutschen bundestag
die für die verteidigung von freiheit
ihr leben gegeben haben meine damen und
herren wenn sie
wenn sie an einer sachlichen debatte
interessiert sind dann hören sie auf
antifaschisten mit randalierenden
plündernden gewalttätern in einen topf
zu werfen
alle das behaupte ich jetzt mal weil ich
glaube zu wissen alle parteien des
demokratischen spektrums distanzieren
sich selbst reden von marodierenden
banden wie beim g20-gipfel in hamburg
oder anderswo die am tv die sie
verbieten wollen gibt es als
organisation gar nicht weshalb und sie
auch nicht verbieten haben in
wirklichkeit meinen sie mit antifa
womöglich alles was hier im hause links
von ihnen sitzt die öffentlich
rechtlichen medien
hören sie auf und sich selber abzulenken
ihre tage sind gezählt
sie sind dieses hauses ich würde ihr
antwort ist absurd und deshalb lehnen
wir ihn ab
vielen dank und gruß für die
spd-fraktion und irgendwelche jetzt als
nächste rednerin folgen martina renner
aus der fraktion die linke sie ist
sprecherin für antifaschistische politik
das passt ja nächste gegnerin ist die
kollegin martina gerne fraktion die
linke
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren der
demokratischen fraktion
wissen sie erwünscht dieser zwischenruf
sagt mehr über sie als über mich
der vorliegende antrag der wäre auch
eine lächerliche art und weise absurd
wenn wir außer acht lassen würden vor
welchem hintergrund wird die diese
diskussion heute führten
als wir vor es war etwa knapp einem jahr
schon einmal über einen ähnlichen antrag
sprachen taten wir das wenige wochen
nach der ermordung von walter lübke
machtwort ruft die ab die seit dem sind
zwölf weitere menschen von rechten
terroristen ermordet wurden so viele
bezogen auf den zeitraum wie seit den
blutigen jahr 1980 nicht mehr
ich meine die morde und attentate der
wehrsportgruppe hoffmann und der
deutschen aktionsgruppen auch
innenminister seehofer der wohl über
jeden verdacht erhaben ist mitglied der
anti fahrt zu sein
er kennt unumwunden an mittlerweile die
größte bedrohung die geht vom
rechtsextremismus aus
wenn uns also der parlamentarische arm
des rechts terror erneut diese
überflüssige debatte aufzwingt sollten
wir über das dahinterstehende kalkül
nachdenken und uns klar werden
es ist eine beleidigung des andenkens an
walter lübke mercedes körper und alle
anderen todesopfer rechter gewalt und es
ist ein versuch die politische debatte
zu unterbinden die notwendig ist um
rechten terror zu stoppen und weitere
tote zu verhindern
meine letzte rede
die habe ich mit einem dank an die
antifa beendet und das möchte ich heute
von kritisieren das verbot des rechts
terroristischen netzwerks kombat ihn
hätte es ohne die recherche des
antifaschistischen portals exif nicht
gegeben und sie waren es auch die
wesentlich dazu beigetragen haben die
falsche behauptung der behörden der
mutmaßliche mörder von weiteren sei
jahrelang nicht mehr in erscheinung
getreten er sei so etwas wie ein recht
das schläfer zu korrigieren danke exil
die vereinigung der verfolgten des
naziregimes verbindet die erinnerung an
die verbrechen des nationalsozialismus
mit antifaschistischer praxis in der
gegenwart danke auch an tv vor ende
magazin wie das antifaschistische
infoblatt der rechte rand und lotta
beobachten die entwicklung der extremen
rechten mit ausdauer profunder kenntnis
und ehrenamtlichen engagement danke
unserem magazin in verschiedenen städten
haben sich in den letzten monaten
migrantengruppen gegründet auch als
reaktion auf den rechten anschlag in
hanau im februar
diese gruppen die verbinden
antirassistische und antifaschistische
kämpfe und schlagen damit eine dringend
notwendige brücke
damit stehen sie auch in der tradition
des migrantischen selbst schutzes gegen
rechte übergriffe in den 90er jahren
danke migranten antifaschistische
archive wie das abschieds in berlin oder
aida in münchen sind wissensspeicher von
denen politische initiativen ebenso
profitieren wie journalisten und
journalistinnen diese archive das sind
auch unbequem bequeme chronisten sie
lagern informationen über die
aktivitäten und netzwerke der extrem
rechten die leute vibrionen decke und
andreas kalbitz gerne vergessen machen
würden aber es wird nichts vergessen
danke den erschließen
wir vergessen nicht wir vergessen nicht
die namen der ermordeten und auch nicht
die namen der mörder
wir wissen über die netzwerke bescheid
und über die geistigen brandstifter
wir kennen die leerstellen der
ermittlungen und die versäumnisse der
offiziellen erinnerung und wir wissen
auch unsere stärke das ist die
solidarität
sie verbindet uns auch hier im haus über
parteigrenzen hinweg und ländergrenzen
kennt sie auch nicht sie ist die
erinnerung unsere erfolge und auch das
gedenken an unsere niederlage für einen
gemeinsamen kampf für ein besseres
morgen für alle danke frankfurt ohne
gewähr
nächste rednerin ist die kollegen dr
bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren
marion wendt hat die
verfassungsrechtliche zuneigung die die
afg gerade erfährt er ausführlich
beschrieben deswegen kann ich mir das
spaß und ich kann zu diesem antrag zu
diesen anträgen und zu der
sinnhaftigkeit dieser anträge mich
eigentlich auf einsatz beschränken auch
der jugendverband der afg wird ja schon
seit längerem vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet und genau währenddessen
bringen sie es fertig hier einsatz
einzubringen der da lautet
jugendorganisationen dürfen nicht zu ein
buch stellen extremistischer
bestrebungen werden
das ist schon eine besondere form des
aber witzes und ich frage mich ernsthaft
ob die ausschließliche lektüre der
jungen freiheit und legale drogen
ausreichend zu was einzubringen von
einer eindruck stelle kann man bei der
afg schon lange nicht mehr reden bei
ihnen ist der ganze dann gebrochen und
dieser antrag hat den charakter das ist
wie jemand versinkt bis zum hals im
braunen schlamm und deutet auf andere
sie könnten sich die füße stutzig machen
alle anträge da es zu diesem thema
beruhen auf einer falschen behauptung
antifaschismus sei dasselbe wie
gewaltbereiter linksextremismus diese
gleichsetzung verfolgt eine zweck und
zwar den zweck das
zivilgesellschaftliche engagement gegen
den rechtsextremismus mundtot zu machen
diese gleichsetzung
widerspreche nicht nur ich diese
gleichsetzung widersprechen auch die
verfassung zu behörden und auf diesen
trick der afg sollte hier niemand
hereinfallen
ja es gibt gewaltbereiten
linksextremismus und an dem gibt es
nichts zu romantisieren der
polizistinnen und polizisten das
menschsein abspricht wer die
durchsetzung politischer ziele durch
gewalt rechtfertigt der wird auch
dadurch nicht besser dass er sich ein
antifa aufkleber auf das sage ich nicht
nur mir sondern das sage ich auf denen
die es angeht ins gesicht jede
generation muss diese unabdingbare
voraussetzung der freiheitlichen
demokratie neu lernen wieder neu lernen
das ist eben so was die afg aber will
ist das zivilgesellschaftliche
engagement gegen rechtsextremismus zum
schweigen zu bringen
wir müssen uns doch alle der tatsache
stellen dass zur geschichte der
bundesrepublik immer wieder auch
eklatantes versagen des staates gegen
rechtsextremismus gehört hat und vor ort
heute berg herr wendt sie sind viel
jünger als ich
fragen sie die veteranen aus der
westdeutschen antischall wie es war 1992
nach rostock nach rostock lichtenhagen
zu fahren und tage lang ohnmächtig dabei
zuzuschauen wie auf menschen
brandanschläge verübt wurden
reden sie mit malen ostdeutschen
altersgenossen wie sie die
baseballschläger jahre der 90er jahre
überlebt haben reden sie mit denen und
lassen sie sich doch mal beschreiben
die mord serie des aniston und der
umgang der staatlichen behörden damit
das vertrauen erschüttert hat dass
dieser staat menschen jeder hautfarbe
jeder herkunft vor dem rechtsextremismus
schützt es war und ist auch
zivilgesellschaftliches engagement das
den finger in diese wunde legt die
aufdeckung rechtsextremer rechts
netzwerke da gebe ich natürlich recht
und da wird ihnen auch die der
verfassungsschützer unter vier augen
zustimmen es bis heute angewiesen auf
informationen die antifaschistische
akteure der zivilgesellschaft zusammen
fragen reden sie mit diesen leuten und
lassen sie sich auch nicht in der
behauptung abhalten lässt sich selbst
als antiker bezeichnet bezieht sich
damit automatisch irgendwie positiv auf
die ddr auch das ist quatsch die antifa
in ostberlin und in dresden hat der
stasi auf flugblättern und transparenten
die wahrheit entgegen gehalten war
neonazis auch in der ddr
und da saßen sie herr meier noch ganz
bequem mit bremen parteien wird immer
wieder alle parteien werden immer wieder
ihr verhältnis zum extremismus und zu
gewalt klären müssen
klischees über sich selbst oder über
andere machen dafür blind ja es gibt
auch im linken parteienspektrum
anbiederung an revolutionären kitsch und
relativierung politischer gewalt und es
gibt umso heftigere auseinandersetzungen
um diese frage aber bevor sie sich
hierzu sehr entspannen sich selbst als
partei der mitte zu bezeichnen union und
fdp
das ist auch kein zauberspruch auch sie
müssen die grenze zum extremismus immer
wieder ziehen und dass es ihnen nicht
immer leicht fällt haben wir auch in den
letzten monaten gesehen nicht nur in
trier
in deutschland fiel vor langer zeit
öffentlich ein satz den ich für
grundfalsch halte ich möchte ihnen aber
mit erlaubnis des präsidenten trotzdem
zitieren ich distanziere mich
ausdrücklich davon aber vielleicht wird
er ja rechts und links an der einen oder
anderen selbstgewissheit nachdem in der
bundesrepublik eine synagoge mit
antisemitischen parolen beschmiert wurde
und dieser tat hunderte weitere
anschläge folgten erteilte jemand den
rat meine deutschen mitbürgern insgesamt
sage ich wenn ihr irgendwo ein lümmel
erwischt vollzieht die strafe auf der
stelle und gebt ihm eine tracht prügel
das ist die strafe die er verdient wie
gesagt der rat ist grundfalsch
er stand aber nicht von der antifa er
fiel in einer rundfunkansprache von
konrad adenauer nach der schändung der
kölner synagoge 1959 dass wir es heute
besser wissen und besser machen müssen
wir alle immer wieder beweist vielen
dank manuela rottmann abbau im
rechtsausschuss für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen und ihr folgt jetzt die
vorsitzende im innenausschuss andrea
lindholz aus der union
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der antrag da
ist inhaltlich dünn ist rechtlich
fadenscheinig und ist vor allen dingen
politisch durchsichtig und wir werden
ihn daher auch ablehnen ja auch
linksextremismus ist eine große gefahr
für die sicherheit in deutschland das
haben der angriff auf das zdf team in
berlin vor kurzem die gewalt in leipzig
connewitz und auch die ausschreitungen
beim g20-gipfel in hamburg deutlich
gezeigt ihre kernforderung im antrag
aber für ein bundesweites verbot der
antifa zeigt wie wenig sie von unserem
recht straße eingesetzt und auch seinen
gegnern verstehen oder bewusst nicht
verstehen wollen die antifa ist und geht
davon aus ihn ist das sehr wohl bewusst
lässt sich gerade nicht unter dem
strafrechtlichen verfassungs begriff
fassen sie ist eben keine feste
organisation sondern sie besteht aus
linken sie besteht aus
linksextremistischen und gruppen und
auch aus autonomen gewalttätern und
verbieten lassen sich nur einzelne
gruppen und klar erkennbare
organisationen und unser
verfassungsschutz der ja auch von ihrer
seite zumindestens wenn ich ein gauland
anblicke schon mal abgeschafft werden
sollte beobachtet genau diese antifa
gruppen sowie er auch teile der afg
beobachtet und mindestens oder über 40
antifagruppen stufen die landesämter als
extremistisch ein
das bundesinnenministerium hat zum
beispiel dem verbot der
linksextremistischen internetplattform
links unten punkt in die media
zugestimmt und gezeigt dass es den
linksextremismus sehr wohl im blick hat
politisch durchsichtig ist ihr antrag
weil er natürlich wie so oft nur
linksextremismus und islamistischen
terror als zentrale gefahr nennt den
rechtsextremismus als das größte
aktuelle sicherheitsrisiko dem blenden
sie wie üblich aus auch blenden sie aus
der 86
prozent aller straftaten im
rechtsextremismus
körperverletzungsdelikte sind sie
verschweigen dass rechts terroristen
walter lübke und in halle und hanau 13
12 weitere menschen auf brutalste art
und weise ermordet haben sie
verschweigen die rechtsextreme gefahr
vielleicht deshalb weil der
hauptverdächtige im mordfall übte
nachweislich an herrn hüppe gespendet
und für die afg plakate geklebt hat und
fakt ist liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der afg dass sie nicht mal in der
lage sind die extremisten aus irgendwann
aus ihren eigenen reihen zu entfernen
und da kann ja parteivorstand gerade mal
beschließen was er will
extremisten meine sehr geehrten juden
kolleginnen und kollegen aber egal ob
sie politisch oder religiös motiviert
sind sie dürfen in unserer gesellschaft
in unserer mitte keinen platz haben
sie wollen die freiheitliche
demokratische grundordnung zerstören
und genau dieser wille er lässt sich
nicht nur auf der rechten sondern auch
auf der linken seite manchmal
zweifelhafte anschauen
abgeordnete von linken und ich kann sie
nicht ersparen in diesem plenum und auch
von grünen im europäischen parlament
tragen symbole der antifa obwohl sie
genau wissen dass sie damit mittelbar
auch die gewalt von linksextremisten
extremistischen gruppen unterstützen und
dann statt sich von gewalt und
extremismus klar zu distanzieren fordern
ganz aktuell die grüne jugend die jusos
und auch die linke jugendorganisation
die auflösung des verfassungsschutzes da
haben sie dann etwas mit der afg gemein
ich halte sie
für sehr zweifelhaft hilfreich wenn die
spd-vorsitzende via twitter die antifa
unterstützt und ich glaube sie würde es
nicht noch einmal tun nebenbei die
gesamte deutsche polizei als latent
rassistisch abqualifiziert hinterher
erkundigt mich sind man sich dann ob der
vorwurf eigentlich richtig ist hinterher
macht man termine vor ort man sollte
vorher denken bevor man kommuniziert wir
stehen als demokraten schulter an
schulter gegen menschenverachtende
rechte hetze die unser
gesellschaftliches klima vergiftet und
die auch die morde an walter lück wird
die morde in halle und den hanau
befördert hat aber es gibt es nicht nur
von rechts ein wirklich trauriges
beispiel in dieser woche und wir haben
es auch im innenausschuss behandelt war
die linke hetzkampagne in der taz von
der bis heute jede entschuldigung fehlt
eine kolumne unter dem deckmantel der
satire die polizisten als müll
bezeichnet und fordert sie auf die auf
einer deponie zu entsorgen menschen die
ihre gesundheit riskieren für uns und
uns alle in diesem land schützen werden
entmenschlicht und als müll bezeichnet
so weit ist es gekommen ich kann ihnen
ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin immer noch
erschüttert ich bin fassungslos und auch
fassungslos darüber dass es dafür bis
heute keine entschuldigung gibt
unsere männer und frauen in den
sicherheitsbehörden sie verdienen
unseren dank sie verdienen unsere
anerkennung sie verdienen unseren
respekt und sie verdienen und den schutz
und sie verdienen auch dass wir uns
hinter sie stellen anstatt sie pauschal
zu beleidigen und der generalverdacht zu
stellen oder jetzt hier in berlin mit
dem neuen anti diskriminierungsgesetz
gleich komplett in den für general
verdacht mit einzubeziehen
ich will an dieser stelle noch eins
sagen auch die polizei ist nicht
fehlerhaft sie ist ein spiegelbild
unserer gesellschaft geld kommt kritik
ist erlaubt
egal an welcher stelle aber es ist die
frage mit welchem maß wie man kritik übt
und hier muss ich sagen finde ich die
letzten tage erschütternd was wir
erleben wir sollten anständig bleiben
bei jedem maß an kritik und an dem ich
keine partei aus aber liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen von der heydt den ihr
antrag ist so dünn er ist so
durchsichtig dass wir ihn ablehnen
werden vielen dank
vielen dank frau kollegen der kollege in
schmiden willi schmider sie können sich
jetzt entscheiden welche ihre beiden
nachfolge reden auf eine gute verzichten
muss sehr schön so wie mir das dann
weiterhin sagen er hat vielen dank
nächster gegner ist der kollege martin
hess die fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrter reservierte kollegen wir
sollten bei aller differenz in der sache
hier in dem hause eines tunlichst
unterlassen unwahrheiten zu verbreiten
und kollege politikers haben sie heute
getan sie haben hier ernsthaft behauptet
unsere fraktion hätte keine
positionierung zum le mans bis zum
heutigen tage abgegeben das ist
nachweislich unwahr in der debatte zu
diesem thema war ich rede und ich habe
diese tat klar und deutlich verurteilt
wir sollten bei der wahrheit bleiben die
anträge unsere fraktionen sind von
vitaler bedeutung für unsere demokratie
denn in unserem land mutter
linksextremismus von teilen der politik
und gesellschaft eben nicht klar und
deutlich vorteil von toleriert
verharmlost und sogar unterstützt das
hat auch die heutige debatte wieder
eindrücklich gezeigt dieses
ungleichgewicht bedroht zunehmend unsere
demokratie und das können und dürfen wir
nicht zulassen
die spd-chefin es konsolidiert sie sich
am ersten juni auf twitter mit antifa
und schrieb weiter antifa sei keine
organisation antifaschismus ist eine
haltung die für demokraten
selbstverständlich sein sollte und
genauso wird ja heute wieder
argumentiert auch von grünen und linken
aber damit täuschen und belügen sie die
bürger dieses landes antifa ist in
wirklichkeit keine demokratische haltung
sondern eine antidemokratische
gruppierung die massive gewalttaten
gegen andersdenkende und polizeibeamte
verübt und die antifa und das auch an
ihre adresse frau lindholz ist bezogen
auf regionale gruppierungen eben sehr
wohl eine organisation mit struktur sitz
und repräsentanten der verfassungsschutz
führt ist 47 antifa gruppen in seinen
berichten als linksextremistisch auf um
diese gruppen können und müssen verboten
werden
und zwar so schnell wie möglich wenn die
antifa gewalt eskaliert immer stärker in
baden württemberg haben
linksextremistische gewalttäter am rand
einer corona demo einen demonstranten
beinahe getötet der verfassungsschutz
baden-württemberg sieht in der häufung
der koordinierten körperlichen
übergriffe eine völlig neue entwicklung
und das landesinnenministerium wand
wurde gestiegenen militanz linker
gewalttäter frau heller und andre sie
haben heute auch in dieser debatte wie
das sich genau mit diesen gewalttätern
gemein gemacht und ich frage sie werden
sie das auch dann noch tun denn wir die
ersten toten von linker gewalt beklagen
müssen solange können und dürfen wir
nicht warten wir müssen jetzt
entschlossen handeln und auch sie meine
damen und herren von der union ich kann
sie nicht ausnehmen ihre parteifreunde
haben in mecklenburg vorpommern eine
bekennende linksextremisten zur
verfassungsrichterin gemacht eine frau
die das ddr unrechts geschrieben in
schutz nimmt und die mauer verteidigt
das ist ein schandfleck in der historie
ihrer partei das von uns geforderte
bekenntnis zu einem anti extremistischen
grundkonsens ist das absolute minimum
dass man von einem überzeugten
demokraten erwarten kann hört dies
antrag nicht zustimmt der vorbei dort
ein klares bekenntnis zu unserer
demokratischen grundwerten und trägt so
die mitschuld an der eskalation linker
gewalt wir dürfen niemals gewalt als
mittel der politik akzeptieren egal von
welcher seite verteidigen sie deshalb
unsere demokratie entschlossen gegen
alle extremisten
und stimmen sie unserem antrag zu
ich habe gerade vernommen aus der
fraktion der linken dem begriff tracks
sagt war das gerade zutreffend gibt's ja
jemand der sich dazu bekennen will
freiwillig hetzler sehr gut an der
grenze es muss am alter liegen
herzlichen dank als nächste rednerin
spricht sie uns die kollegen wie wir
leben spd fraktion liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte damen und herren
an den bildschirmen
der vorliegende antrag zum verbot der
antifa beschwert aus sechs seiten eine
linke gefahr und den
antikapitalistischen sturz unserer
parlamentarischen grundordnung die art
degeneriert sich wiederholt als opfer
und rheydt willkürlich zahlen die fakten
aus dem bundesverfassungsschutz
berichten aneinander
richtig ist dass es gewaltbereiten
linksextremismus gibt selbst einige
meiner fraktionskollegen waren von
linker gewalt bereits getroffen
selbstverständlich wird derart
motivierte gewalt in unseren stark
verurteilung bekämpft richtig ist aber
auch dass es vier mal mehr rechts als
linksextremistisch motivierte straftaten
gibt die art und weise wie 7 daten aus
den bericht interpretieren suggeriert
ein mäntelchen der bürgerlichen mitte in
wirklichkeit verbergen sich dahinter
fremdenfeindlichkeit menschenverachtung
und rassismus
was spricht noch aus diesem antrag der
fdp könnte das schlicht panik nach der
einstufung des gedanken brandenburger
landesverbandes als verdachtsfall durch
den verfassungsschutz seien diese panik
hätte ich an ihrer stelle auf erst
diesen montag erklärte das
brandenburgische innenministerium und
ich darf bitte zitieren die
brandenburger fdp hat sich seit ihrer
gründung stetig radikalisiert und wird
mittlerweile von bestrebungen dominiert
die ganz eindeutig gegen unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
gerichtet sind zitat ende
als brandenburgerin mit langjähriger
fahrer und aus kreis und landesebene
auch mit der ard ist es für mich eine
große politische bedeutung und ist es
ganz wichtig dass wir nach thüringen das
zweite bundesland sind die jetzt das
jetzt diesen schritt geht
die entscheidung des brandenburgischen
verfassungsschutzes ist folgerichtig
längst überfällig und zeigt dass der
rechtsstaat funktioniert
sehr geehrte wählerinnen und wähler der
asd verschließen sie vor dieser
gesinnung nicht die augen entscheiden
die sich für demokratie
die ard will die antifa fabriken mussten
wir auch nochmal dieses mäntelchen
was verbirgt sich denn hinter dem
begriff angefahren sind es wirklich nur
prügelnde autoanzünder randalierende
chaoten wie der afg antrag zu verstehen
gibt kein antrag nicht auch ein
lebensprinzip sein
die definition die definition unserer
jugendorganisation der jusos ist ein
beispiel dafür dass antifa und
grundgesetz zusammengehen
ich darf die user zitieren wir begreifen
unsere antifaschistisches engagement als
akt der verteidigung gegen
antidemokratische kräfte jeglicher art
ich darf noch ein satz zitieren wir
engagieren uns im gegenprotest und
stellen einer rechten ideologie zu jeder
zeit unsere idee einer solidarischen
offenen und gerechten gesellschaft
entgegen ende des zitates und natürlich
es ist ein paradoxon und weil wir die
debatte anfangs schon taten möchte ich
es nochmal aus meiner perspektive sagen
dürfen nicht jeder antifaschist ist
automatisch ein demokrat doch jeder
aufrichtige demokrat ist automatisch ein
antifaschist
und im gegenzug ist verurteile gewalt
bin 66 wenn antifa ich bedanke mich für
eure aufmerksamkeit
wir nehmen an mir ganz am ende ihrer
rede noch mal mit 1 2 sätzen eine kleine
korrektur vorgenommen hat an eine
aussage ihres fraktionskollegen uli
goltsch axel müller ist nach meiner
liste der nächste redner er ist in der
unions fraktion und mitglied im
innenausschuss korrigieren sie ungern
habe ich heiße nicht alex oder axel
müller überzugehen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren die
reden über zwei anträge der fw fraktion
die bereits die gleiche zielrichtung
haben ein verbot der antifa jedoch
bereits der titel des antrags demokratie
erhalten bundesweites verbot der antifa
prüfen endlauf die antragsteller einer
nicht zu überbietenden einseitigkeiten
unaufrichtigkeit er suggeriert nur die
im politischen spektrum extrem links
angesiedelten gucken zu denen die antifa
bewegung zweifelsfrei gehört sei die
bedrohung schlechthin für die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
in wahrheit ist es doch so liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das alle
extremisten gleich ob von links oder
rechts die feinde der rechtsstaatlichen
demokratie sind daher darf eine
wehrhafte demokratie und das sind die
schmerzhaften lehren die wir aus der
weimarer republik ziehen müssten
darf eine wehrhafte demokratie weder auf
dem rechten noch auf dem linken auge
blind sein
der antrag der afd zeugt jedoch von
einer kaum zu überbietenden einäugigkeit
beide anträge zielen nur auf den
extremismus von links und blenden die
ihn von rechts nahezu vollständig aus
das kann man wenn man politisch so
gestrickt ist wie die afg objektiv
betrachtet ja sogar noch verstehen
jemand 60 gerne den ast ab auf dem er
mit drauf sitzt was ihnen meine damen
und herren von der afg jedoch nicht
durchgehen lassen sind die halbheiten
mit denen sie ihren antrag bekunden
zur untermauerung ihrer behauptung die
gefahren die vom linksextremismus
ausgingen stellten heute nach den
gefahren des islamistischen terrors eine
der größten bedrohungen für gesellschaft
demokratie und staat da verweisen sie
auf zwei verfassungsschutzberichte aus
dem jahre 2017 und 2018 als ehemalige
richter punkt eine zeugen belehrung in
den sinn
der zeuge wird darauf hingewiesen dass
er wahrhaft aussagen muss also nichts
falsches sagen durfte aber auch c
vollständig aussagen muss wer wie sie im
jahre 2020 einen antrag mit der
entsprechenden zielrichtung eines
verbots der antifa und
linksextremistische kräfte stellt muss
doch auch die enorme zunahme des
linksextremismus begründen können und
der allgemein zugängliche neueste bka
bericht über politisch motivierte
kriminalität für das jahr 2009/10
spricht eine ganz andere sprache als sie
in ihren anträgen 2009 10 waren es 41
tausend 177 politisch motivierte
straftaten 22.300 42 mussten dem rechten
spektrum zugeordnet werden und neun 1849
hatten einen linken politischen
hintergrund der rest konnte nicht
zugeordnet werden hasskriminalität aber
auch fremdenfeindlichkeit und in
erschreckender weise antisemitische
straftaten haben zugenommen
um nicht in das übliche rechts links
schema zu verfahren des oftmals ihrem
hause stattfindet sage ich in aller
deutlichkeit wie er von der union aber
auch die überwiegende mehrheit in diesem
land und ich gehe davon aus auch in
diesem haus dient jede art von
politischer
extremismus ab daher ist die von der ard
im wahrsten sinne verkürzte darstellung
der wirklichkeit unredlich unredlich
schon deswegen weil sie ablenkt von den
verstrickungen den eigenen
verstrickungen in die rechte szene
eines steht jetzt schon fest an die
widersprüchlichkeit esta antrag nicht zu
überbieten
in drei der fünf pluspunkte verlangen
sie dass der verfassungsschutz gegen die
antifa tätig werden müssen
nachdem bekannt worden war dass der
verfassungsschutz den flügel und die
junge alternative als verdachtsfall
einstufen würde hat der ehrenvorsitzende
der afg hegau land gegenüber der bild am
sonntag gesagt dass er die abschaffung
des verfassungsschutzes für nicht falsch
halte interessant auch was sich der
rechte frontmann hüppe zum
verfassungsschutz äußert er stuft ihn
als exekutivorgan für den völker
auflösenden und als pervers zu
bezeichneten geist eines george soros 1
woher kommt eigentlich ihr sinneswandel
in bezug auf den verfassungsschutz zu
guter letzt sind beide anträge auch
instinktlos und das ergebnis eines ganz
bewussten ablenkungsmanövers sie werden
in einer woche eingebracht in der der
prozess gegen die mutmaßlich rechts
terroristischen mörder des ehemaligen
kasseler regierungspräsidenten walter
lübcke begonnen hat und in einer woche
in der der brandenburgische
innenminister gesagt hat dass der
dortige fw landesverband künftig auch
der beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz unterlegen
nicht zuletzt weil herr calvin
fdp-fraktionsvorsitzende zusammen mit
dem thüringischen fdp afd entschuldigung
landesvorsitzenden der bis vor kurzem
noch eine der galionsfiguren der
äußersten rechten der achterbahn
beide hatten in der vergangenheit
verbindungen zu rechtsradikalen greifen
herr calbe zugang zu hd und meine damen
und herren wir lassen uns von diesen
einseitig beladenen karren der afg nicht
spannen von kleinen ihre anträge daher
dankeschön die welt würde die welt die
vornamen verwechslung zu entschuldigen
kommt wahrscheinlich wegen der
besonderen verbundenheit zu meinem
kollegen alex müller aus der fdp
fraktion also nehmen sie das als zeichen
der wertschätzung meiner seite und
entschuldigen sie mich für diese
verwechslung
als nächste redner spricht sonst ihr
gehege lehnt spd fraktion
[Applaus]
man kann ja erst mal herr präsident die
kolleginnen kollegen man kann sich seine
groupies nicht aussuchen aber so riesig
sagte ja als riese hat ja sich versucht
in der zerstörung der cdu jüngst der der
presse die afg braucht kein riese zur
zerstörung ihrer selbst das macht sie
immer selbst mit solchen anträgen ich
gratuliere ihm dazu eine großartige
leistung die sie heute wieder vollbracht
haben
und das sage ich als jemand der durchaus
auch schon zielscheibe von aktionen
einzelner antifa aktivisten geworden ist
jetzt komme ich zu meiner beweisführung
ihrer selbstzerstörung
these 1 antifa ist doch sowas wie das
faktotum der deutschen stimmungs politik
jeder hat eine meinung zu und jeder kann
was zu sagen an kiefer und vor allem
anti antifa geht immer so funktioniert
das prinzip und sie betreiben
mystifizierung eine völlig absurde
dämonisierung manche gelegentlich auch
romantisierung these 1 these 2 kommen
wir jetzt zu afd antifa wie sie
skizzieren ist doch für sie flüchtlinge
2.0 ihr neues scheitern des
geschäftsmodell als der anschlag auf
meinem büro passierte erreicht mich von
afg abgeordneten und deren groupies
wiederum nur häme selbstgerechtigkeit
schaden freunde das ist ihr menschenbild
der mensch ist der afg im nichts weg er
ist ihr nur mittel und stimmvieh und das
ist der sinn dieses antrags heute
und deshalb stelle ich fest dass die
bundesrepublik im ganzen gewiss kein
antifa problem hat aber die fdp hat ein
vehementes faschismus problem in form
ihrer selbst kommen wir zum nächsten
punkt these 3 betrachten wir das noch
mal nüchtern und dann heißt es dass
antifaschismus zusammen mit anti
antisemitismus und antirassismus die
säule des kampfes gegen
rechtsextremismus ist und die sollte uns
alle bis auf gewisse ausnahmen doch ein
und wenn wir dann ganz ehrlich sind auch
wenn uns das nicht passen mag ist es
doch so auch dass einzelne antifa
aktionsgruppen die zum teil in der tat
ein brüchiges verhältnis zur demokratie
haben wesentliche aufklärungsarbeit
gegen neonazistische netzwerke und
aktivisten leisten es ist so punkt und
andererseits ist es leider auch so ich
habe es ja erlebt dass in einem akt
ziemlich unromantisch und ziemlich
widerlicher selbstgerechtigkeit 1
aktivisten die sich selbst als antifa
begreifen mein büro zerlegt haben und
das machen im gestus der menschlichkeit
und das ist ihre tragik eigentlich damit
menschenverachtung üben kommen wir jetzt
aber kommen wir zum fazit
erstens die afg hat ein vehementes
faschismus problem
zweitens die afg hat ein antifa problem
denn viele aktivisten der antifa in
städten und gemeinden ihr wirken und das
stört sie wieder glücklicher weise stört
sie das drittens
habt ihr an die partie afd
ein ich nehme in anführungszeichen
antifa problem
sie regen sich auf über
staatsfeindlichkeit starts fremdheit
demokratiefeindlichkeit ja was sind sie
denn etwas staatsferne des staatsrates
demokratie fördern muss als sie selbst
habe ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
sie reden also von sich selbst und dann
kommen wir zum vierten punkt
und das ist die größte bekannte
ungewollt unabsichtlich gelingt ihm was
wahnsinniges denn sie machen hier
werbung für den antifaschismus und nicht
nur das sie betreiben für einzelne gar
nicht so wichtige antifagruppen
unfassbare werbung sie propagieren sie
sie mystifiziert
sie können sich bei ihnen bedanken was
sie haben woran sie leiden das ist ein
anti fand asmus oder an team vater
morgana wir auch immer das ist das
syndrom
denn die angriff war herr kollege die
ist
die afg der strohhalm an denen sie sich
verteidigen medienumfrage werden endlich
wieder zu steigen dank des 4 0 gewinnt
für die spd-fraktion und er bekommt viel
applaus nicht nur von seiner eigenen
fraktion sondern auch von den grünen
auch aus reihen der linken auch von der
die fraktion darum bitten darauf zu
achten dass das nicht den eindruck
erweckt als seien wir in einem
fußballstadion oder in einem konzertsaal
bei aller bei der wahl ihrer eigenen
begeisterung der kollege lehnt auch für
sie gilt dass sie vielleicht beachten
dem wunsch zur rede zu ende zu kommen
ich wollte ich es nicht das wort
entziehen das wäre unangemessen gewesen
nachdem sie ihre gruppe ich so
begeistert haben aber bitte beim niesen
beachten sie einfach darauf als letzter
regen hast du diesen tagesordnungspunkt
hat das wort der kollege hans jürgen
irmer cdu csu fraktion zu einem 4
minuten leute womöglich herr präsident
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen zur dna der cdu und csu
bundestagsfraktion gehört ist auf allen
ebenen rechtsextremismus
linksextremismus und islamismus
gemeinsam zu bekämpfen das unterscheidet
uns von rechts außen unterscheidet uns
von linksaußen es gibt keine guten
radikalen von rechts schlechte radikale
von links radikal ist per se immer etwas
schlechtes und wenn sie wenn sie von
rechts ausnahmen von der afg das muss
ich jetzt anhören
endlich einmal dazu kommen würden sie in
gleicher intensität mit dem
rechtsextremismus zu beschäftigen wie
mit dem linksextremismus wäre das für
ihre glaubwürdigkeit eindeutig besser
und das gleiche gilt natürlich umgekehrt
auch für die sed erben die ja letzten
endes auf den linksaußen auge ebenfalls
blind sind leider hielt es auch für
teile für teile betone ich ausdrücklich
für teile von spd und grünen
ich erinnere an die debatte über die
rote hilfe meine damen und herren
der bundesinnenminister hat im november
20 18 öffentlich gefordert wir prüfen ob
die rote hilfe verboten werden muss
findet persönlich zu recht eine
organisation die öffentlich erklärt wir
unterstützen die letzten verbliebenen
raf-terroristen die drei die noch auf
freiem fuß sind ihren lebensunterhalt
durch banküberfälle bestreiten und dann
kommt die rote hilfe und erklärte
öffentlich wünscht den genossen viel
erfolg und alles gute
und das wird noch unterstützt von den
jusos und teilen der spd meine damen und
herren da habe ich kein verständnis für
um das sehr deutlich sagen herr kollegen
lernen sie alles mit dem
führungsverhalten versehen möchte mit
nachweis auch die zeit insgesamt
diejenigen nicht davon abhalten
pünktlich züge und busse zu erreichen
beziehungsweise den flieger frau
kollegin windholz und ab heute merck
haben zu recht auf den artikel in der
tat hingewiesen finde es unerträglich
was dort gelaufen ist und ich bedanke
mich bei der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft bei der gdp aber
auch bei pro polizei bei denen dass sie
auf mich erklärt haben wir klage
einreichen zu wollen wegen
volksverhetzung ich halte das für
richtig meine damen und herren
man stelle sich einmal vor
irgendjemandem dieser republik hätte
öffentlich erklärt alle asylbewerber
würden auf die müllhalde gehören es wäre
eine welle der empörung zu recht durch
dieses land gegangen ich würde mir
wünschen es geht eine genauso gleiche
welle der empörung durchs land wenn
jemand erklärt 250.000 polizeibeamte
gehören auf dem müll halte unerträglich
meine damen und herren
und in diesen kontext gehört auch was
die linken angeht der strategie kongress
der linkspartei in kassel vor wenigen
monaten wo ein mitglied aufgestanden ist
öffentlich erklärt hat das eine prozent
der reichsten das erschießen wir da
sitzt jemand dabei wie eric singer
erklärt lächelt naja wir schießen sie
nicht gleich wir lassen sie für uns
arbeiten was ist denn das für ein
menschenbild für ein rechtsverständnis
meine damen und herren unter diese
kategorie passt natürlich auch die
antifa sind schon sehr verwundert
darüber dass die antifa von teilen der
spd so verniedlichend hier begriffen
beschrieben wird immerhin gibt es 47
antifa verbände in deutschland die vom
bundesverfassungsschutz am pc oder von
den länder verfassungsschutzämtern
beobachtet werden doch nicht aus lauter
jux und tollerei und zwar deshalb weil
es bestimmte merkmale gibt die man mit
antifa verbinden muss dazu gehört
grundsätzlich der kampf gegen den
sogenannten kapitalistischen bundesstaat
abschaffung der fdp abschaffen eine
demokratie etablierung in der
sozialistischen diktatur und das zweite
merkmal ist gewalt gegen sachen gewalt
gegen menschen mit entsprechenden
hilfsmitteln wie eisenstangen molotow
cocktails und anderes mehr
das ist nicht mein verständnis von
demokratie meine damen und herren
schlicht und ergreifend das
unterscheidet uns diametral und ein
letzter satz weil die zeit leider weg
räumt weg läuft herr kollege grösch sie
haben gesagt jeder antifaschist ist
demokrat nein umgekehrt wird ein schuh
draus jeder demokrat ist antifaschist
wenn es sich an die freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung helfen die
bestehenden gesetze das ist für mich
entsprechend demokratisches
grundverständnis aber nicht umgekehrt
meine damen und herren
und deshalb müssen wir alles dran
in dieser republik die linksextreme
genauso zu attackieren zu bekämpfen wie
die rechtsextremen und die islamisten
dann wird ein schuh draus dankeschön
vielen dank herr kollege gerne das wort
für eine kurzen dimension erhält der
kollege hennef deflation
vielen dank herr präsident meine damen
und herren lieber kollege wenn wir von
der antifa reden dann reden wir von
denen die an jedem ersten hunderte von
autos in brand setzen wir reden von
denen die halb hamburg verwüstet und in
schutt und asche gelegt haben
wir reden von denen die mit
pflastersteinen von hochhäusern auf
polizisten werfen und damit billigend in
kauf nehmen dass die polizisten ihr
leben verlieren
damit und mit vielen anderen
körperverletzungen mit vielen anderen
terrorakten hat sich die antifa zur
legitimen nachfolgeorganisationen der
roten armee fraktion gemacht und ich
frage deshalb gibt es hier einen
einzigen in diesem hause der tatsächlich
mal bereit wäre klar aufzustehen und zu
sagen diese menschen diese organisation
die all das verantworten gehört verboten
ich habe das hier die ganze zeit nicht
ein einziges mal gehört die einen haben
zwei sätze gebraucht um rechtsradikal
itt zu kommen die nächsten haben sich
für das zivilgesellschaftliche
engagement bedankt der antifa und dritte
meinten diese leute seien automatisch
demokraten etwas erbärmliches habe ich
in diesem hohen hause noch nie erlebt
und ich kann ihnen nur sagen würde ich
glaube die bevölkerung in der
bundesrepublik deutschland wird das
spätestens am heutigen tage bemerkt
haben
mit diesem personal hat die demokratie
in deutschland fertig vielen dank thomas
horn von der alb über das
viele gerne sie an das mikrofon schon
gefahren die sie wollen antworten bitte
sie haben das wort
sie müssen jetzt nur drücken die band
will gerne die gelegenheit wahrnehmen
der gebotenen kürze zwei sätze noch
hinzuzufügen was die beurteilung der
antifa und ihre auswirkungen angeht da
gibt es durchaus eine gewisse
inhaltliche affinität ich erinnere daran
antifagruppen weisen auf ihren homepages
häufig genug darauf hin dass sie mit
erfolg irgendwelche veranstaltungen
verhindert haben meine damen und herren
ob das vorlesungen sind
wissenschaftliche vorträge
veranstaltungen öffentlicher art auch
immer
das hat mit demokratie nichts zu tun das
sage ich sehr deutlich das ist eine das
zweite ist herr kollege
was nicht nur ich aber andere auch zu
recht kritisiert haben
sie wären insgesamt gesehen dramatisch
glaubwürdiger wenn sie sich mit dem
gleichen werft wie sie sich mit
linksextremismus zu recht beschäftigen
auch mit dem rechtsextremismus
beschäftigen würden und das
unterscheidet sie von uns wir machen es
eben auf beide auf beiden ebenen
[Applaus]